le poisson le plus consommé en Amérique et en Occident —
est le saumon.
Le saumon a aussi été l'objet d'un pillage,
mais ça n'est pas forcément arrivé avec la pêche.
Voici le Connecticut, mon État d'origine.
Le Connecticut abritait beaucoup de saumon sauvage.
Si vous regardez cette carte du Connecticut,
chaque point sur cette carte est un barrage.
Il y a plus de 3 000 barrages dans l'État du Connecticut.
Je dis souvent que c'est pourquoi les gens du Connecticut sont si coincés.
(Rires)
Si quelqu'un pouvait juste débloquer le chi du Connecticut,
à mon avis, ce monde pourrait être infiniment meilleur.
J'ai fait ce commentaire
à une convention d'agents des parcs nationaux,
quelqu'un de Caroline du Nord s'est approché de moi et a dit :
« Vous savez, vous ne devriez pas être si dur avec votre Connecticut,
parce qu'ici, en Caroline du Nord, nous avons 35 000 barrages. »
C'est une épidémie nationale et internationale.
Il y a des barrages partout,
et c'est précisément ce qui empêche le saumon d'atteindre ses frayères.
L'étape suivante fut l'aquaculture,
et le saumon est un grand succès, au moins d'un point de vue numérique.
Au commencement de l'élevage de saumon,
jusqu'à 6 kg de poisson sauvage pouvaient être nécessaires
pour faire un seul kilo de saumon.
L'industrie s'est malgré tout grandement améliorée.
Elle est passée en-dessous de 2 pour 1,
bien que ce soit un peu de la triche,
car dans la production de l'alimentation de l'aquaculture,
on mesure les granules —
des kilos de granules par kilo de saumon.
Ces granules sont du poisson réduit.
Alors le vrai ratio — le poisson au départ et le poisson à l'arrivée —
est plutôt difficile à dire.
Dans tous les cas, et c'est tout à son honneur,
l'industrie a réduit la quantité de poisson par kilo de saumon.
Mais nous nous sommes malheureusement lâchés
sur la quantité de saumon produite.
L'aquaculture est le système alimentaire à la croissance la plus rapide au monde.
Il croît d'environ 7% par an.
Bien que nous ayons besoin de moins par poisson
pour l'amener sur le marché,
on tue toujours beaucoup de ces petits poissons.
Ce n'est pas juste le poisson que l'on nourrit de poisson.
Nous donnons aussi du poisson aux poulets et aux cochons.
Nous avons des poulets et ils mangent du poisson,
mais bizarrement, nous avons aussi du poisson qui mange du poulet.
Parce que les restes de poulet — plumes, sang, os —
sont broyés et donnés aux poissons.
Je me demande souvent :
y a-t-il un poisson qui a mangé un poulet qui a mangé un poisson ?
C'est une sorte de refonte de l'histoire de l’œuf et de la poule.
(Rires)
En fin de compte, le résultat est un bazar terrible.
Nous parlons d'environ 20 à 30 millions de tonnes de créatures sauvages
qui sont enlevées de l'océan, utilisées, et broyées.
C'est l'équivalent d'un tiers de la Chine,
ou de tous les humains des États-Unis,
qui seraient capturés dans l'océan chaque année.
Le dernier des quatre est quelque chose d'un peu amorphe.
C'est ce que l'industrie appelle corégone.
Beaucoup de poissons intègrent ce terme de corégone,
mais cette histoire se raconte le mieux
à travers ce classique de l'innovation culinaire américaine,
le sandwich Filet-O-Fish.
Le Filet-O-Fish a commencé avec le flétan.
Il a vu le jour lorsque le propriétaire d'une franchise a découvert
que le vendredi, personne ne venait à son McDonald's.
La communauté catholique avait besoin de poisson.
Il est alors allé voir Ray Kroc et a dit :
« Je vais faire un sandwich au poisson, avec du flétan. »
Ray Kroc a dit : « Ça ne va pas marcher.
Je veux faire un Hula Burger,
et il y aura une tranche d'ananas sur un pain à burger.
Mais allons-y, faisons un pari.
Le sandwich qui se vendra le plus sera le sandwich gagnant. »
C'est assez triste pour l'océan que le Hula Burger n'ait pas gagné.
Il a donc fait son sandwich au flétan.
Malheureusement, le coût du sandwich s'élevait à 30 centimes.
Ray voulait que le sandwich coûte 25 centimes,
alors il s'est tourné vers le cabillaud.
On connaît tous le sort du cabillaud de la Nouvelle-Angleterre.
Maintenant, le Filet-O-Fish est fait avec du colin d'Alaska.
C'est la plus grande industrie de poisson aux États-Unis,
1 à 1,5 milliard de kilos de poisson sont pêchés chaque année.
Si nous épuisons le colin,
l'option suivante sera probablement le tilapia.
Personne n'avait jamais entendu parler du tilapia il y a 20 ans.
Il convertit efficacement les protéines végétales en protéines animales,
et il a été une bénédiction dans le tiers-monde.
C'est une solution extrêmement durable.
Il passe de l'œuf à l'état adulte en neuf mois.
Le problème, c'est que le poisson ne fait pas ce que l'Occident veut qu'il fasse.
Il n'a pas ce qu'on appelle un profil de poisson gras.
Il n'a pas les oméga-3 EPA et DHA
qui nous permettront de vivre éternellement, du moins le croyons-nous.
Alors que faisons-nous ?
Avant tout, qu'en est-il de ce pauvre poisson, le clupéidé ?
Le poisson qui représente une part énorme de ces 20 à 30 millions de tonnes.
Une possibilité que des protecteurs de l'environnement ont soulevée est :
pourrions-nous les manger directement au lieu d'en nourrir les saumons ?
Il y a des arguments pour.
Ils sont extrêmement économes à amener sur le marché,
une partie du coût du carburant des crevettes,
et tout en haut de l'échelle en efficacité carbone.
Ils sont aussi riches en oméga-3, une très bonne source d'EPA et de DHA.
C'est donc une possibilité.
Et si nous devions nous engager sur cette voie, à mon avis,
au lieu de payer quelques dollars le kilo, ou quelques dollars par tonne,
et investir dans l'aquaculture,
pouvons-nous diviser par deux la capture et doubler le prix pour les pêcheurs,
et traiter ces poissons de cette manière ?
Une autre possibilité, bien plus intéressante,
est de s'intéresser aux bivalves, en particulier les moules.
Les moules sont riches en EPA et en DHA, elles sont similaires au thon en boîte.
Elles sont aussi très économes en carburant.
Le transport d'un kilo de moules équivaut au tiers du carbone requis pour le bœuf.
Elles n'ont pas besoin de poisson fourrage.
Elles acquièrent leurs oméga-3 en filtrant l'eau des micro-algues.
C'est de là qui viennent les oméga-3, et non des poissons.
La micro-algue fabrique les oméga-3.
Ils sont simplement concentrés dans le poisson.
Les moules et bivalves filtrent d'énormes quantités d'eau.
Une seule moule peut filtrer des dizaines de litres chaque jour.
Ce détail est très important lorsque l'on observe le monde.
En ce moment, la nitrification, l'usage abusif de phosphates dans nos cours d'eau,
causent une énorme prolifération d'algues.
Plus de 400 zones mortes ont vu le jour ces 20 dernières années,
d'énormes responsables de disparition de la vie marine.
Nous pourrions ne pas du tout considérer le poisson.
Pourquoi pas un légume ? Ou bien l'algue, le varech ?
Toutes ces variétés différentes qui peuvent être riches en oméga-3,
peuvent être également riches en protéines,
d'excellents nutriments.
Elles filtrent l'eau tout comme les moules.
Et ce qui est drôle,
c'est qu'il s'avère que vous pouvez nourrir les vaches avec.
Je ne suis pas vraiment fan du bétail.
Si vous voulez élever du bétail,
à une époque où les ressources en eau sont limitées,
vous cultivez des algues dans l'eau, pas besoin de les arroser —
une considération majeure.
Et le dernier poisson est un point d'interrogation.
Nous avons la possibilité de fabriquer un poisson d'élevage
qui apporterait un gain net de protéine marine.
Cette créature devrait être végétarienne,
devrait grandir rapidement.
Elle devrait s'adapter à un climat changeant,
et devrait avoir ce profil de poisson gras,
ce profil en acides gras, en EPA, DHA, oméga-3, que nous recherchons.
Ça existe sur le papier.
J'enquête sur le sujet depuis 15 ans.
À chaque fois que j'écris une nouvelle histoire, quelqu'un me dit :
« On peut faire tout ça. On a compris comment.
On peut produire un poisson avec un gain net de protéines
et qui a des oméga-3. »
Génial.
Ça n'a pas l'air d'être en développement.
Il est temps de le faire.
Si nous réussissons,
30 millions de tonnes de poisson, un tiers de la capture mondiale,
restent dans l'eau.
Voilà où je veux en venir.
Voici ce que nous avons poursuivi.
Nous pensons avec notre appétit plutôt qu'avec notre cerveau.
Mais si nous allions vers ça, ou une partie de cette configuration,
nous pourrions avoir un peu plus de ça.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)